and just to remind you how amazing sam
raimi is as a director and what he had
in mind for spider-man 4
that was going to have the vulture
played by john malkovich
as the bad guy here we have here an
animation prep that was going to be used
as reference to them film the
live-action version of
this which is the final battle
spider-man 4-way would be wow
against john malkovich's vulture and i'm
just going to play this footage over for
you guys there's not much dialogue here
but man there is one thing for sure
about this footage
and it is brutal just imagining the way
sam raimi has directed spider-man movies
in the past how it's so cinematic
glorious and epic this feels terrifying
as of all dragon was
michael keaton's vulture and i thought
he did a good job but
john malkovich's vulture would have been
a villain
that would have been a big problem for
spider-man just the way he tosses him
around
he's stuck in him eventually
it really sucks we never got to see this
movie because
all this footage right here looks
fantastic this is also one of the things
i really hope to see in spider-man no
way home
it's just maybe a reference to this to
like this battle did end up happening we
just never saw the movie about it
because i do want to see
older peter parker but the reports that
doctor octopus would be digitally the
age it makes us think maybe also toby
maguire will be digitally
since we saw him in spider-man 3. either
way this is just some stuff i wanted to
show us
spider-man fans out there who watch the
channel you gotta admit this is awesome
heidi ho rejectos we're gonna watch
today from 3c
films spiderman no way home new teaser
deleted by sony plus update
what was in the teaser
[Music]
i come before you today
humbled
and humiliated
to ask you for one thing
[Music]
i want you to release the spider-man no
way home trailer
[Laughter]
black widow featurette you got it hey
guys thanks for watching this video it's
always a wonderful day in the
neighborhood
spider-man 3 specifically
breadcrumbs because y'all tagged me and
something so minor so minuscule but the
fact that it's the only new thing we got
right now is spiderman away home
i guess i'm forced to make a video i
can't blame you though it's been a
couple of days because nothing
newsworthy has been dropping lately so
i'mma make this a topic
you can do it chris is that there is a
new international title that is released
online that had a tiny little teaser
video
of the title with one tiny thing that
happens to it that has got the whole
spider-man community going crazy
discussing more about the story of
spider-man no way home and just for damn
fun because it is spider-man talk we
even got
unseen footage of the final battle for
the cancelled sam raimi spider no way
nick looks amazing and just makes me sad
we did not get this movie let me need
you spider-man
give me your opinions down below i know
we are just sick and tired of talking
about this movie we want some footage
we lost some of that trailer here but
someone out there has not fixed the damn
door for it to happen
we are not sick of everything that's
been happening nope this is
fun guys absolutely the biggest part of
any movie
is the anticipation of it all that's why
they say
sell the sizzle not the steak we're
feeding into the sizzle don't you see
yeah yeah that's what we're all doing as
consumers of the products taking people
hungry for more content
then when the content's over what's on
to the next thing now what's the next
thing yeah
second no way home premieres what's it
for spider-man 4. i suggest diving into
it let's talk about how desperate we
have gotten from spider-man news that i
swear
every day i jump online i see new people
coming out
with a different trailer day
countless fake screen shots
on tom holland's birthday or on june
10th when i was your boy telling you
right here
ain't gonna happen until two or one week
before black wins that's what i'm
thinking that's the way marvel rolls
y'all
so end of this month or first week of
july is when we can expect to see this
thing i'm not moving off that timeline
and if it doesn't happen then
i don't know when it's gonna happen
y'all but like i was saying fans have
gotten so crazy
and desperate with wanting to see some
footage from trailer that people out
there
have made their own footage that
actually looks like something
we'll probably end up seeing in
spider-man no way home i want to bring
this to your attention
this is fake i still think it looks
awesome this is made by a visual effects
artist by the name of max
arnhemmer who his footage got taken way
out of context and was just thrown
online and people really thought this
was legit footage from spider-man no way
home especially
that looks great and i keep teasing this
statue of liberty battle people were not
fighting him for creating it so it made
it look even more real
that this video was very copy strike
like if it was a studio doing it but the
reason i'm bringing this up even though
it's fake is because this has been a
scene that we've been hearing about
spiderman the big final battle in this
movie will take place
on the statue of liberty whether that is
with tom holland by himself
or somebody else good little people and
andrew garfield which is what i'm hoping
for
this is everything we've been hearing
from the plot leaks and we've even seen
set photos where the statue of liberty
will play some sort of big role in the
spider-man movie where
the government decides to put a big
captain america shield on top of it who
knows for what reason
they they gotta do one of those like oh
this guy
stole from me but he did such a good job
at stealing we should hire him yeah to
make our stuff even better
yeah so that's what they should do with
this visual effects artist yeah like he
did this fake thing that people took was
real and people were up in arms about it
and the copyright strikes are happening
but then kevin
feige is like hold the phone let me see
that footage
success hires him this is exactly the
kind of ability we need at marvel
studios
worked for us now i think this is going
to be a fantastic setting for the final
battle and from everything we've heard
that
it's the sinister six even if it's
spider-man by himself the thought of
all three spider-man on the statue of
liberty fighting because like this is
the third tom hall in spider-man movie
and we're barely getting to the part
where he's going around new york city
doing some fighting now we got a little
bit of that but the boy spent a lot of
it in dc in that film also still
something cool to just wet your palette
and like i said if you spread this
around if you share it make sure you
credit the artist guys he worked hard on
it
and he helped keep our appetites in
check but now getting to an official
teaser that was released online by an
international sony account that
continues to be the villains
of the spiderman no way home news if you
guys remember all the way back to me
talking about spiderman no way home on
this channel it was always a damn
international channel trying to take
and leak some stuff out and we didn't
know if it was just some random intern
wanting to have some fun or
it was legit information they wanted to
throw at us and right here we have it
and right here from the sony pictures
argentina account they decided to reveal
the international title which is
spider-man cincamino akasa which does
basically translate to no way home so
it's not that big of a deal that title
it's almost exactly the same but the
part that has gotten so desperate and
clinging on to like what does this mean
is by the end of this little title
spider-verse glitch
and spider-man fans lost their minds
around the world
didn't we go through this we did with it
yeah exactly with that one
walking through the offices of spiderman
no way home they revealed the title and
we got the same sort of glitch but
this time around it's confirmed it even
more for people because the thing that
we are really reaching on here is
this glitch confirms the spider verse
because it's a very similar glitch to
spider-man into the spider-verse
other fans are digging deeper and
pausing it at the right moment where the
entire logo turns
red and thinking oh this isn't
confirming the spider verse
this is matt murdock
he's like kind of looks like him yeah
mcu now it's all but confirmed about
matt murdock daredevil heck if i had to
put my money on it i'm more convinced
that daredevil is in the movie as
opposed to the spider people
and that's still me believing the spider
people are in it but i just want to keep
my expectations on check there i guess i
can see why people
believe further more into this because
in the one where tom hollands
and dia and jacob battle i were walking
it goes in on a white board and the
glitch could have just been
it's like yeah it makes you think of
spider-verse at the taiwan division was
out so people might think of one
division but at the end of the day it
could have just been a cool transition
that they did okay from whiteboard to
actual title logo reveal it could have
just been nothing
but with this you're looking at only the
title and then the title has the
spider-verse glitch so that makes it
even
more yeah definitive a point of that
yeah
so i understand where the consumers are
coming from they're messing with us
we're all consumers of the great marvel
product
it could just be a random choice right
here it is kind of curious why they
chose a glitch like that
and your boy the plot thickens further
here i was thinking this meant nothing
it was just i was kind of exaggerating
scratching at breadcrumbs but
if i had a spidey nickel for every time
something came out online
by the sony people and then was randomly
deleted
i'd be one rich spidey food because let
me tell you that's exactly what just
happened right now that argentina
account that missouri
uploaded their titles
what could it be about what's happening
here and i guess it caused so much hop
up
they deleted it i don't get why they do
that because if anything i feel that
brings way more attention
to just leave it alone and not say
anything at all the fact that they
deleted it makes me think
there was something bigger here and i
didn't even see it what i honestly think
though
happened and why they deleted it is just
because it was causing too much
attention
this intern does not want to get fired
or get his job taken off from being the
argentina twitter account user for sony
what do you mean causing too much
attention that attention is grand we're
gonna see that title
spider-verse if it has that glitch and
even our u.s
distributed trailers or uk you know what
i mean english
all right we're all going to see it
eventually like this if anything just
creates more hype
yeah absolutely because they're not
revealing anything other than the
translation of the title and a slight
twist
it's the logo with the red filter on it
like i can't imagine what that could be
spoiling it's not yeah i mean it has the
fans talking about it yeah
it didn't delete it it creates more hype
yeah and i mean i can't imagine what
they would undo
in deleting it that hasn't already been
done like a hundred times by other posts
you know i bet it was intentional
they're purposely holding back
all the marketing material so that when
they're ready they go full throttle with
it a poster a trailer a teaser
a catch entertainment weekly article
the fact that there was a lot of people
getting hyped online over something so
tiny and
random sonny was like no no we need to
save that hype
for when the actual trailer comes you
delete that argentina sony damn
international accounts
either way the damn journey of
spider-man news that gets deleted online
continues here's the rest of the video
[Music]
something that we know probably would
have worked to high heavens is the
cancelled spider-man 4 movie with sam
raimi now
one of the only reasons i bring this up
is because sam raimi is back in the mcu
and there's been
big rumors and speculation which is just
all they are
nothing huge is that if another fighter
event does happen in spider-man no way
home
we could be seeing a continuation of the
world of tobey maguire and andrew
garfield
each one of them getting their own
spin-off movies and continuing that
spider world which i would
love it whoa what the rumor is that they
would each get their own
spin-off movies that's a little too much
spider-man
that's a lot of spiders
depends on the light because then we'll
get miles morales
yeah oh absolutely then let's get miguel
o'hara because we need diversity yeah
go against spider-gwen leave it all five
or six simultaneously running
independent spider-man series where they
all you know do spider-man stuff
individually and then occasionally team
up for a spider-verse so it is like you
know this
villains of the spider-verse isn't
working what if we just did a bunch of
different spider-man
or steamed up a million spiderman and
then spun them all off into movies that
we've already messed around with
like it's the thing i'm like if they
spin off another andrew garfield series
like
what what what if it's not great i want
to hear from you guys out there how do
you feel about all these little
breadcrumbs we're getting right now for
spider-man 3 are you desperate for this
trailer
can you give a prediction of when you
think it'll come out would you have
liked to have seen this spider-man 4 how
do you think loki connects to the
overall movie editing and everything be
sure to leave your thoughts down below
don't forget to like subscribe
follow me on twitter at 3c film but as
always i'm chris
take care thank you chris you rock man
thank you hell yeah hell yeah more
spider-man more
way to go argentina more titles more
more glitches
proud of you guys subscribe to 3c films
if you haven't done so already hit the
like button on this video
last but not least let's do a pic
sarah campbell you deserve a cameo in
the new spider-man no way home but not
because
everyone's in the movie it's because of
the bruce camels
campbell camel bruce camel sarah camel
now you're an anamorph
how do you like that do you ever read
animorphs as a kid anyway i was trying
to connect you to bruce campbell cause
he's got a bit part in every single sam
raimi spider-man movie so i'm thinking
what if you showed up as his like
alter-ego
sidekick i feel like you could get
animated do some crazy hijinks you know
maybe for one
scene annoy toby maguire and then we'll
have a a piece to nerd out extra over
cause we'll be like oh we know her she's
a celebrity now oh my god
so uh i hope you're doing well sir i
don't know how you do it i
don't either